The Joe Rogan Experience yeah I feel
like zero connection to birds like I
don't want a pet bird yeah right that
dog pet cat even pet weird and weird
pets like pet horse I get it yeah I get
it too yeah but like a pet snake the
[__] are you doing oh that's you got a
monster that lives with you this is got
a monster that you feed that's all that
is that is a heartless serpent yeah they
size you up the only reason why they're
not eating you is because you're not big
enough
or they're not big enough they're not
big enough and if they grow but this is
what I was talking about the guy
the python hunting I think in Florida
now you anyone can hunt a python and you
get you get a prize too like you get
money then you get serious money I don't
know if it's like a thousand bucks what
did you ever see the video of the guy
there's something wrong with the ceiling
and they're they're pulling on the
ceiling and the pythons were in the
ceiling and it collapses yes and you see
like three or four pythons in his
[__] ceiling and they're huge huge
where the [__] is that place and how do
I make sure I never go there
where was it Malaysia holy [__] Malaysia
watch this video this is so crazy oh God
look at this look at the size of that
bro
how many is there there's two three
there's the tail that might be one this
is three all over three
three all over ten feet long in the
[__] ceiling even when you get them
out how you going back to sleep how do
you go back to sleep after going back to
sleep and you're not getting them out
they obviously have nested up there oh
my God look at the size of the size of
these [__] so they must have
heard them scurrying around the ceiling
they call one in my development a python
yeah how big was it I think it was like
10 feet oh my God and that's like that's
I mean they found a record-sized one
recently I think it was 18 feet
I think it was 18 or 19 feet and they
think they they get bigger like they
don't even know how big they ultimately
get this is not their environment right
did you see this video what these guys
were
killing over 300 pythons and a boa
constrictor but they did like they
killed the wrong one or something like
that one of these was pregnant had like
50 in it inside of it so why are they
killing these things uh either I mean
they're in Florida and they're oh so now
I realize he killed the wrong one or
something like that yeah
the longer videos like I'm killing it is
I don't need to see that
I mean the whole thing is weird that
they allowed those as exotic pets and
then these people just let them go in
the swamp
and then you just keep multiplied don't
you remember that apparently that's only
a part of the problem though I thought
that was the whole problem another part
of the problem was that there was a
wildlife research facility where they're
studying pythons
and somehow or another it got destroyed
in a storm and the pythons got out uh
Andrew I think
was that so yeah so that's also part of
the problem so some of it is exotic pets
and some of it is these ones that they
release from this research facility but
it's more mind-boggling to me how
just a couple
can turn into completely taken over how
it took over everything because they're
invasive there's that nothing knows to
fear them but even when they're little
don't you think I figure what is the
survival rate if the gate if they're in
the water with Gators and you have
Bobcats yeah hurricane Andrews that it
was that that was that is part of the
part of the Python problem right I think
they don't know exactly what you know
which percentage comes from the or the
pets from the 1970s and [__] people that
go right thousands of specimens of
exotic species Escape their cages and
enclosures during the passing the storm
through the South Dade County State
Environmental inspectors reporting
reported 10 days after the hurricane
Witnesses spotted hundreds of large
snakes and non-venomous snakes loose
wow hundreds and now those hundreds are
half a million there's a half a million
pythons they estimate
so because Burmese python invasion of
South Florida Everglades populations of
raccoons and opossums dropped roughly 99
and some species of rabbits and foxes
effectively disappeared species that had
long flourished here being decimated by
the aggressive newcomers wow
wow
that's amazing yeah that's why it's it's
a free-for-all NASA go ahead it is a
free-for-all you know what else they've
still got it in the Everglades they
spotted Nile crocodiles
so they don't know how they got in there
they don't know if someone's pet but
they had a kill on site order for Nile
crocodiles they don't know if it's a
breeding pair they don't know you know
they just they have spotted at least one
Nile crocodile in the Everglades
crocodile is a whole different animal
that's a whole different it's a whole
different set but I
that's like a wolf compared to a German
Shepherd right I was in in Costa Rica
kids were just doing like a vacation
standing whatever and I remember being
in the water
in the beach yeah yeah swimming around
and I didn't go the the the beach
dropped off where we were was like a
river that let in the in the ocean was
close and it dropped by a little bit and
I mean I was in there it was touring
around I wouldn't go too deep and I stay
close and the next day we went back
there it was a big freaking
crocodile slide
no he was spanked on there yeah and I
went oh my God and I just couldn't
believe how no one else was in the water
yeah
yeah could have been it it could have
been it could have been that see that
I'm safe in Florida kayaking we went on
um a tour of uh the crocodile habitat
with my kids when they were the youngest
were like
they're probably like six and eight
somewhere around then yeah and uh it was
so creepy dude I was so like every time
they moved like I got away from the edge
get away from the edge I was like I was
so hover parenting which is like and the
kids are crazy like I want to sit on the
railing I'm like [__] no you can't sit
on the railing right like don't do this
like if you go in that water I'm going
in that water too and we're both
yeah the guy who did that what happened
the guy was with the dog oh yeah I did
see that but that was a little one that
was it was a little dog but yeah a
little later too it wasn't a big Gator
and that guy did get his dog back with
that guy's a [__] Savage I don't know
how you did that with your kids you must
have been freaking freaking out freaking
out and we saw them and they slide into
the water right in front of you there
was this alligator slide yeah or
crocodile slide rather so you're on this
body of water and then right where the
bank is you see the Crocs sunning
themselves and then you see them slide
into the water it's so creepy it is
creepy it's so creepy because they're
just killing machines and you're you're
in just this [__] boat it's just a
boat
and you see them on land too you don't
think they're fat they can move on land
yeah they move they move quick they move
faster than we can they can run faster
than us
wait wait what is this
it says hundreds of alligators or
crocodiles behind them I don't know in
their tent so they camped on the beach
did you see the one on the right God
look at that it looks outside his teeth
oh my God oh my God
oh my God
you literally camped at the spot where
they go
what did they do staring there
what the [__] do you do there you leave
do you leave yeah what if you run into
another group of them right like higher
up the hill right imagine you're out of
breath you're right up the hill run up
the hill you get to the top and you
realize there's more alligators right
there there's ten times the amount yeah
and you're out of breath now you know
you can't run no I mean you gotta do
some research before you go there I
think you know what freaks me out more
young kids they're Reckless
laughs